will the U.S government for the first
time ever default on our debt payments
that we have and if we do what does this
really look like in the last hundred
years six countries have defaulted on
their debt will we really go through it
as America the greatest nation in the
world how do we get here in the first
place why are Republicans and Democrats
fighting is this really a leverage game
that the Republican controls the house
and these guys want to raise a debt
limit and their son will be for you
lower your spend that you we're not
going to raise it they're like no we
want all of it and then some so then
president Trump in the town hall meeting
says let them default because they're
bullying you so we're going to see if
McCarthy's gonna hold ground and say
nope we're not doing this Janet Yellen
said we could be running out of money as
early as June and I'd scare the crap out
a lot of people in the market so there's
a lot of things going on we're going to
dive into this to really see is us going
to default or not so during chaotic
uncertain times sometimes you know
people don't have somebody to talk to
you can't talk to your wife your husband
your family your mom your dad because
you're running a business you're a
salesperson you're a c-suite executive
you got so many things going on you need
to talk to somebody and you want to go
talk to a therapist but you don't want
to go into an office because you're
sitting out with somebody talking to
them three other people sitting and
waiting like I want this thing to be
discreet where can I go to talk to
somebody today's sponsor better help
allows you to meet with a therapist in a
discreet way better help is the world's
largest therapy service and it's 100
online would better help you can tap
into a network of 25 000 licensed and
experienced therapists who can help you
with a wide range of issues to get
started you just have to answer a few
questions about your needs and
preferences in therapy that way better
help can match you with the right
therapist from their Network then you
can talk to your therapist however you
feel comfortable whether it's via text
chat phone or video call you can message
your therapist at any time and schedule
live sessions when it's convenient for
you if your therapist isn't the right
fit for any reason you can switch to a
new therapist at no additional charge
would better help you get the same
professionalism and quality you expect
from an in-office therapy but with a
therapist who is custom picked for you
more schedule and flexibility and add a
more affordable price so get 10 off your
first month by going to betterhelp.com
forward slash valuetainment the link is
also below so whether you go to better
help.com forward slash valuetainment or
you click on the link below you get 10
off for your first month so if you get
value from this video give it a thumbs
up and subscribe to the channel let's
get right into it first thing we need to
all know about is the fact that the
government has access to you know tools
that we don't have you and I don't have
they can manipulate money in ways you
and I cannot do but before we get into
the levels of manipulation they can do
let's kind of figure out how the
government gets money in the first place
there's two ways to get money one is
either through taxes the other one is
through bonds so taxes is taxes
corporate individual any other way that
they get their money the other one is by
you and I buying bonds from them
treasury bills t-bills t-bonds
short-term midterm long term that is one
way that they get money from the public
we'll talk a little more about the
treasuries later on but let's first look
at the history of debt ceiling in
America so the power to issue money is
specifically granted to the US Congress
by the Constitution the debt ceiling was
established by the second Liberty Bond
Act of 1917. it was not created as a
restriction on the federal government's
ability to borrow it it was created to
simplify the process and provide the U.S
treasury would more flexibility and
managing the country's debt so pre-1917
the government had to get each line of
debt that they wanted to get approved it
was one by one by one and like listen
this is taking too much time can we kind
of speed up the process instead of
having to do this and then boom World
War One happens that was a perfect
excuse for them to say why don't we do
it through a debt ceiling that we don't
have to get approval every time
obviously the government likes that
because they need less approvals so
here's what's crazy about it it went as
a way to improve and speed up the
process and streamline it to now being
politicized and they're using it as a
weapon and a point of Leverage against
each other which is causing a Mayhem
that we have today it's causing Congress
to be divided so now Congress has raised
extended or revised debt ceiling nearly
a hundred times since it was established
even in 1939 and 1941 Congress
established the first limits that
allowed the U.S treasury the ability to
issue new debt as long as the total
amount outstanding remained under a
specified ceiling now if I was to ask
you since 1960 we've raised revised
extended the debt limit nearly 78 times
right how many times you think it was on
the Republican president how many times
you think was on a Democratic president
ready here's the numbers 49 times who's
under Republican president 29 times was
on the Democratic president why because
most of the time when the president is
President the house is owned by the
opposite side so if Republican president
Demps control the house if the
Democratic president Republicans own the
house you see how this thing kind of
works out so meaning even though it's a
Republican president typically the left
owns the house they're the ones that are
raising the debt limit but listen both
sides do it regularly because they want
to spend more money you know the chance
of getting these guys to want to say you
got to spend less good luck getting
these guys who want to spend less on
either side of the aisle so now last
hundred years let's look at how many
governments have actually defaulted okay
first one Germany 1932 1948 caused by
the inability to repay the reparations
imposed after World War One the default
and subsequent economic instability
contributed to the rise of the Nazi
party that's Germany number one number
two Argentina 1951 1982 2001 2014 2020.
it's fair to say Argentina is the goat
the dynasty of defaulting under
government's uh debt no one's done a
better job defaulting on the debt than
Argentina this is not a good area to be
the best one in due to unsustainable
fiscal policies economic crisis and
volatile commodity prices the defaults
have resulted in severe economic
recessions High inflation and political
stability number three Russia 1998
caused by a collapse in confidence in
the Russian government's ability to
repay its debt leading to a default this
led to a sharp devaluation of the ruble
a severe economic contraction and
political upheaval four Greece 2012
largest Sovereign default in history
causes included structural weaknesses in
the Greek economy misreported government
financial data and the global financial
crisis of 2008 this crisis resulted in
severe austerity measures high
unemployment a significant contraction
in the Greek economy and a European
sovereign debt crisis number five
Venezuela 2017. the Venezuelan debt
crisis was a result of a drop in oil
prices economic mismanagement and
political instability the country has
since experienced hyperinflation severe
shortage of basic Goods in a
humanitarian crisis number six Lebanon
2020 caused by a banking crisis
political instability and civil unrest
resulted in severe economic contraction
hyperinflation and a humanitarian crisis
so if we look at all the six and see
what things have in common this is what
you would find economic mismanagement
political instability external shocks
and unsustainable debt levels so the
question becomes since 1776 we've never
once defaulted will this be the first
time we do no one knows we'll find out
the next four to eight weeks so the main
question becomes what's so different
about America versus Germany Argentina
Russia Greece Venezuela Lebanon how
different are we there's a lot of people
that are saying that that's not going to
happen in our lifetime but why not what
if it does let's take a look at this to
see how different U.S is than these six
countries we just talked about first U.S
treasuries are considered the safest and
most liquid assets in the world it's
seen as pristine collateral or tier one
asset even though some people recently
Basel III is now looking as gold as
being a pristine collateral but still
U.S treasury is all the way at the top
they play a crucial role as a collateral
in Global Financial markets as they are
often used to secure loans margin
accounts and other Financial
transactions so let's look at what
causes U.S treasuries to be pristine
collateral or safe number one low credit
risk the U.S treasuries are backed by
the full faith and credit of the US
government number two high liquidity U.S
treasuries are highly liquid due to
their deep and well-established
secondary Market this allows Market
participants to buy and sell those with
ease making them an ideal form of
collateral three price stability U.S
treasuries have relatively stable prices
compared to other assets like stocks and
commodities the price stability is
advantageous for financial institutions
as it reduces the risk of collateral
value fluctuations why does fluctuations
matter because fluctuations and
collateral value leads to margin calls
you don't want to have margin calls four
Global acceptance the U.S treasuries are
widely accepted and used as collateral
worldwide providing ease of use for
international transactions and last but
not least five repo and reverse repo
Market the repurchase agreement market
and reverse repo Market is a critical
part of the short-term funding and money
markets they facilitate the flow of cash
and securities between financial
institutions central banks and other
Market participants so again this is
what leads to the whole quantitative
easing or quantitative tightening Market
easing if they want to through the FED
let's put more money into the market by
buying bonds from Banks right so that
money goes in the banks get more money
hoping that the banks start lending
money to people and boom the economy
goes up right small business owners all
this stuff quantitative tightening which
like listen we got a little bit too much
money in there let's take money off the
table to tighten the market to tighten
loans and to reduce inflation those are
two different ways they can do but
regardless this causes U.S treasuries to
be very safe investment why many don't
think default will actually happen so
now let's actually go there and say
let's just say we do default what
happens to America here's eight things
that happen number one Global financial
crisis a default would cause severe
disruptions in the global financial
markets as U.S treasuries are used as
the Benchmark for other debt Securities
and as collateral and numerous
transactions this could lead to
liquidity crisis credit Crunch and
increase Market volatility number two
economic chaos financial markets will be
destabilized and the flow of credit will
be constrained number three currency
devaluation the US dollar might lose its
status as a world Reserve currency
leading to a depreciation of the
currency and increased inflationary
pressures number four geopolitical
implications a U.S default could
diminish the country's Global influence
and potentially alter the balance of
power in the International Financial
system number five loss of confidence a
U.S default would erode Global
confidence in the country's ability to
honor its obligations potentially
leading to a decline in demand for U.S
treasuries and a rise in borrowing costs
for the US government six government
shutdown without the ability to borrow
the government would have to cut
spending drastically this could lead to
government shutdowns layoffs of federal
employees and cuts and services
affecting everything from Social
Security payments to military spending
seven legal and constitutional crisis
the 14th Amendment you keep hearing
about to the Constitution states that
the validity of the public debt shall
not be questioned so a debt default
could potentially trigger a
constitutional crisis and last but not
least number eight impact on credit
rating the U.S could lose its AAA rating
status leading to even higher borrowing
costs in the future and further damage
in the country's fiscal situation so in
other words this is catastrophic if that
were to happen so the left and the right
needs to know that that's why they're
both banking on one's going to cave and
they're going to finally say here's the
limit do what you got to do just don't
spend this much you're going to figure
out it would negotiate hopefully they
will neither one of them one's going to
say well if the default is going to be
on you Congress mccarth you're gonna
have to live with us on your legacy and
Congress is going to say hey Biden
forget about you know me as a speaker of
the house you the president everyone's
going to say the first default happened
under a Biden admin Administration
nobody 50 years from now is going to
know who the Congress was they're going
to know who the president was remember
how early at the beginning of the video
I said the government has the ability to
manipulate money and kind of use
collaterals multiple times that you and
I cannot do to kind of make it look like
they're okay there's this concept called
the treasury re-hypothecation just kind
of stay with me here as we go through
this together so this is the practice of
reusing pledged U.S Securities as
collateral for additional loans or
financial transactions so let me explain
to you what this really means so let's
just say I'm gonna go out there and buy
a house so I go to the bank I get a half
a million dollar loan I buy this house I
own the house but the bank really owns
the house so imagine if the bank can use
this house as a collateral it's my
collateral I'm using that I'm going to
pay it back if I don't the bank can come
and take it away from me but what if the
bank now gives that loan out to somebody
and they say we can use this guy's house
as a collateral and they do that two
three four five six kind of sounds like
Pat what are you talking about that's
exactly what they can do they can use
the same exact asset it as collateral
multiple times and no one knows it or
sees it this is kind of what happens
behind closed doors so if this still
doesn't make sense to you to go to a
time in history where we can kind of see
what caused the collapse on the market
it's 2008 you ever seen a movie Big
Short remember the whole mortgage-backed
Securities what was the problem with
that exactly what we just talked about
the rehypothecation concept let me
explain it to you so in 2008 rehab
qualification came under increased
scrutiny due to the risk it composed to
the financial markets as such there have
been regulatory efforts to limit the
extent of rehypropication particularly
in derivatives markets mortgage-backed
Securities were used as collateral many
Financial transactions leading up to
2008 financial market and this was a
misuse it was constantly being used left
and right so look if you do it right and
nobody pays attention to it and
everything is good you can make billions
of dollars it's like having margins
having all your money in your sure trade
account or your e-trade account and
everything's margin but the market keeps
going up and I'm like man look how much
money I'm making I would have normally
only made 50 I just made 150 because I'm
using somebody else's money and then
boom Market crashes now you're like I
thought I was going to lose a million
dollars but no I owe two and a half
million dollars exactly so it's good
when the Market's great it's terrible
when a Market's bad all right so this
next number is going to scare you a
little bit so the US's GDP is roughly 20
trillion dollars right they only have
200 billion dollars in their general
account that's kind of like you miss a
pass a lot of money when I got the
government has 200 billion dollars
that's so much money it's not that's
like you making 200 000 a year okay but
you only have 200 on a bank do you
realize how scary that is what do you
have to do if you only have 200 on a
banking you're making 200 Grand you're
super problematic this is why they're so
scared about what's going to happen but
here's the concern the reason why
Republicans on house are saying listen
lower your expenditure is because this
is what's happened to the interest on
our debt today look at this chart on
what's happening with our interest
payment do you see the sudden Spike that
we went from 600 billion dollars a year
to suddenly a trillion dollars almost a
trillion dollars of Interest payment the
U.S cannot afford that the way we're
going right now this is why they're
saying we got to raise the debt limit
the other side is saying why are you
spending like a crazy man that's kind of
tone it down a little bit then we'll
give it increased debt limit that's the
real battle that's going on so with the
election cycle being here you know one
of the things that's being talked about
is social security right so both sides
wants the 65 the vote the older Social
Security maybe Boomer Market they want
that vote but you know Social Security
was a net positive we were doing okay
with the general account if you look at
this chart here right now what it looked
like in 2008 2009 we're doing okay and
then all of a sudden look at 22 and look
at 23. we're not starting to lose money
and so they're saying we're going to
have payments being missed even for
Social Security so the left is saying
are you promising to not do anything to
Social Security the writers saying this
man we got to kind of figure something
out here because we got to do something
we can't afford to go the way we're
going right now so the left wants to
blame the right the right is saying
let's be responsible this is a whole
Mayhem going on here eventually do not
be surprised if they increase the age
for Social Security benefits 67 69 72
mathematically they're going to have to
eventually go there or stop the benefits
they're obviously not going to stop the
benefits they're probably going to
increase retirement but it's going to be
very painful before they get there so
okay so what's going to happen there's a
couple things that's going to happen
we've never defaulted we've never ran
out of money so they're going to have to
figure it out because neither one of
them want this on their resume but
there's a couple things that people are
speculating could happen one is
continuing resolution can be used until
an agreement is made if the treasury
general account does run out of money
and a continuing resolution is
legislation used by the US Congress to
fund government agencies and programs in
the absence of former appropriation law
others are arguing that Biden should
invoke the 14th Amendment to raise a
debt ceiling himself and that's kind of
problematic because when you look at
14th Amendment section for the validity
of the public debt of the United States
authorized by law including debts
incurred for payments of Pensions and
bounties for services and suppressing
Insurrection or Rebellion shall not
happy question so this is when lawyers
get involved and say well that's not
technically what it says you can't
really do this you can do this you
should do this nobody knows what's going
to happen but here's probably what's
going to happen from 1776 till today
they figured it out they're probably
going to figure it out because these
guys in politics one thing they fear is
not being reelected and if they default
it's gonna be a lot of people not
getting reelected and these guys don't
know how to make money any other way but
politics most of them have no clue of
how to make money in the free market if
they did they probably wouldn't be
involved in politics not taking a shot
at them but you understand what I'm
saying to you so they're probably gonna
end up figuring it out how painful will
it be both sides have to give something
up don't know who's going to give up
more this is when negotiation matters
Olivia McCarthy will it be the other
side we don't know but we're definitely
going to find that in the next four six
eight weeks if you got value from the
video give it a thumbs up subscribe to
the channel I got another video I want
you to watch if you like this one here
will the dollar collapse if you've not
seen that click here to watch it take
care everybody bye bye
thank you